and this just like blew my mind every
show so I do a I used to do a show four
days a week on relationships and every
show I would come out and we would talk
about all this all these different
things in relationships and even married
women would call their husband's partner
and Rolf Dean on Twitter recently put
out a study that said in the past decade
partner has overtaken the term boyfriend
and girlfriend on Twitter for one
significant other so again husband
implies that you submit to their
Authority partner implies that you are
equal and this shows just how deep
feminist language is in our culture
because language shapes behaviors and
behaviors shape language it goes both
ways